la parole est à notre collègue michel
savin pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture
je souhaite évoquer monsieur le ministre
désarroi voire le sentiment d'abandon
que ressentent les éleveurs les bergers
les élus locaux de nos massifs face aux
attaques répétées du loup qui sont de
plus en plus nombreuses ont dénombré
près de dix mille victimes en 2015
combien cette année le nombre de loups
en liberté augment de 20 % chaque année
nous nous pouvons donc plus dire que
c'est une espèce en voie de disparition
de plus 40% des attaques se déroulent
dorénavant en pleine journée certaines à
proximité des habitations
ces attaques récurrentes ont lieu en
dépit des mesures de protection dont
même les environnementalistes
reconnaissent les limites comme seule
réponse l'état a apporté 21 millions
d'euros d'indemnisations versées en 2015
dans le même temps des habitants les
randonneurs ont été victimes
d'agressions très grave de chiens
dressés pour protéger les troupeaux
ce qui pénalise fortement une autre
économie l'activité touristique
ces situations démonte trois choses le
loup gagnent la bataille géographique en
avançant sur les terres le loup gagnent
la bataille économique car la détresse
des éleveurs est tel qu'ils sont
nombreux à vouloir arrêter leur activité
et le loup est en train de gagner la
bataille politique
face à l'absence de propositions des
pouvoirs publics
monsieur le ministre comptez-vous avec
d'autres pays européens
renégocier la convention de berne afin
de faire évoluer le classement de loudes
espèce strictement protégée a simplement
protégé et en attendant soyez vous
favorable à faire réaliser par un
organisme neutre
un comptage le plus précis possible du
nombre de loups présents sur le
territoire national comme le demandent
les associations d'éleveurs et vergers
ainsi que les élus locaux et autoriser
les associations de chasseurs qui
connaissent bien le terrain qui sont des
gens responsables et former d'assurer la
gestion la régulation en continu des
loups des modes qui attaque et troppo
merci pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'agriculture stéphane le
foll
monsieur le président au prado
pagesjaunes doux nom ce sénateur vous
poser une question et
vous entendez que l'état c'est à dire le
ministre à qui vous posez la question
n'aurait rien fait sur le lourd je
voudrais vous rappeler oui mais c'est ce
que vous avez laissé entendre mais ça et
en disant même que le loup j'imagine que
c'est parce que nous sommes là aurait
gagné la bataille politique faudra qu'on
m'explique comment elles ou gagnent la
bataille politique à moi qui est ici des
loups qu'ils soient cachés ça peut
arriver mais monsieur le sénateur un peu
de sérieux quand je suis arrivé c'est
moi qui met en place et après s'étaient
relayés avec ségolène royal un plan de
lutte et de prélèvements sur les loups
jamais mis en place avant jamais avec
des tirs de dissuasion avec la
possibilité de mettre en place avec les
chasseurs locaux des gens qui viennent
cibler les loups qui attaquent plutôt
que d'aller chercher 15 jours après alou
qui n'est pas forcément responsables des
attaques qui ont été conduites oui nous
avons versé des aides monsieur le
sénateur et qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire
ne pas en verser et je voudrais vous
rappeler qu'en 2012 quand je suis arrivé
7 et 8 millions qui était versée par le
ministère de l'agriculture et
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement 22
millions que la population des loups a
augmenté alors vous dites la conférence
demain la convention de berne qui a
signé la conférence de la convention de
berne de ce sénateur
ça fait déjà un moment il s'était pas ce
gouvernement ni le précédent ni celui
d'avant faudrait la renégocier certes
faut-il trouver de majorité pour le
faire et renégocier cette convention
ferait aussi vous l'avez oublié mais
parce que il faut bien connaître ce
dossier renégocier la directive habitats
d'abord avant d'aller parler de la
convention de berne et en même temps on
ne pourra pas s'exonérer non plus du
fait que le loup dans la biodiversité ça
existe si on pense qu'avec des articles
nouveau une renégociation de la
convention de berne
le lou va disparaître là je pense que
vous faites une erreur monsieur
sénateurs donc le travail qu'on a
engagés à la fois sur les dissuasions
sur les tirs qui peuvent être beaucoup
plus rapide sur le nombre de loups qui
peuvent être prélevés qui n'en autour de
30 cl aujourd'hui skinner on est à la
limite de ce qu'on peut accepter au
niveau de la convention la renégociation
de la directive habitats
j'en ai parlé tiens y'a pas plus tard
que hier midi avec le ministre
finlandais qui connaît aussi des
problèmes avec le loup il se trouve
qu'avec les troupeaux de rennes
ils ont des problèmes l'espagne et
l'italie commencent à bouger on essaye
de trouver une solution pour renégocier
mais il faut avoir des partenaires pour
le faire
donc monsieur le sénateur ce sujet on va
poursuivre le travail qu'ont engagée jeu
même fait de nouvelles propositions en
particulier sur la question des chiens
patou qui sont des chiens qui attaquent
aujourd'hui
oui mais ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on
a eu un problème c'est pas moi qui les
ai mis en place échappe à tous les gros
pas tous là dès qu'ils mordent les
petits enfants et les gens qui se
promènent en montagne c'est un vrai
sujet et l'élevage des patous n'est pas
organisée aujourd'hui donc on organisera
et on éduquera aussi n'est pas tout donc
il n'y a pas de loup il faut conclure la
dia contraire une volonté de traiter je
suis obligé de radio qu'est la
régulation monsieur savin monsieur le
ministre je pense que les agriculteurs
les berges et les élus locaux qui ont
entendu votre réponse ironique moqueuse
apprécieront le ton que vous avez tenus
c'est un scandale d'avoir répondu de
cette façon là aujourd'hui déjà sont en
détresse une économie temps péri et
c'est de cette façon que vous répondez
c'est scandaleux